[Music]
one-five their choice
a brisk early hours trade in the famous
fish market that Pizza head shot IKEA
some beautiful coulis it's fresh
some of those fish is only $24 rolls
their newly landed catch selling out to
supermarkets factories and restaurants
from across the UK and as far as Spain
but it is the fishermen here starting to
believe that they are the first ones to
be traded off in the brexit negotiation
to let go and if they do they will never
be forgiven they will go down in history
as the people who are fail destination
up the coast appraisal report regardless
of the rough seas these out of quota
vessels won't be fishing herring and
mackerel
today the skipper George West expects
brexit to change that but fears history
repeating itself that having been sold
down the river once but wouldn't be so
down another one again I think it might
happen there's only the heath thing this
is the map that fishermen want to see
again
UK vessels fish 40% of the fish taken
from UK waters the other 60% will be
other EU nations fishermen would like to
see that number increased to 80 or 90%
like Iceland or the Faroe Islands
currently two-thirds of the industry
exports go to the European Union
tariff-free
they also want this maintain and also
for higher value processed fish fishing
was one of the symbols of the leaf
campaign and there can be no doubting
the scale of the opportunity from no
longer having to share our coastal
waters but even if it doubles in size
it's still only a fraction of a percent
of our national income and any
government trying to seal a deal will
surely prioritize finance or
pharmaceuticals can risking a transition
period really be worth the price of fish
the government's answer yes
transition is a priority and it's taking
the flag in places like Fraser bruh
trying to reassure MPs that the same
calculus won't apply again for the
long-term relationship that's precisely
the fear here nothing is temporary
we had a warning from that from the
other big coastal state around the
Northeast Atlantic in Norway who said
the one thing you must not do is enter
into temporary arrangement because they
will become permanent we are acutely
aware of that again access to the waters
needs to be under the control of the
United Kingdom
what the EU are asking for is actually
worse than the present deal actually
worse than the present deal where we
will have a seat at the table in the
corner without a voice but nothing is
simple in brexit the wider fish industry
eagerly anticipates that boom but we'll
need to keep access to migrant labour to
deal with the glutes and crucially does
not want tariffs on the trade in
processed fish you also export as well
so you want to keep it tariff free the
opportunity for investment is
considerable but we also want
opportunity to trade with Europe on a
competitive basis Finnish progress is
there no not quite finished
ok this is the the pellets looks pretty
turned on as thought to Biskind
and then roses the skins the best bit
have you tried
[Music]
the PM would not still be in number 10
without 13 Scottish Tory MPs who
promised brexit would make the UK an
independent coastal state again that
prospect now delayed MPs trusting that
it will be delivered by 2021 locals here
though mindful of history and the
presence of bigger fish in the brexit
negotiation and not so sure Faisal Islam
Sky News impedes ahead